かわいい！
あざす！
ども！はじ！しょちょです！しゅしゅしゅしゅ！
みなさん...
「キーホルダー」使ってますか？
あの僕もカギにですねキーホルダーていうか
ストラップとか色々ついてるんですよ
どこいったっけな
なくしました...
っていうくらいにですねキーホルダー付けてても
すぐ無くしてしまうんですよ僕は
はじめん、悪い子！はじめん、悪い子！
というわけで皆さんキーホルダーよく付けてると思うんですけども
こういうの見たこと、ありませんでしょうか
あの「伸びるキーホルダー」ですね
昔はこれで色んな人と決闘してきましたわ！！
(所沢：はじめん痛いよ)
これあると思うんですけども
これすごい便利だと思いませんか？
だってカギとかつけてたらさ
こうやってあのカギ開けるときも...
え？これなんで伸びるんだろう...
これ伸びる必要なくね？
というわけでこの伸びるキーホルダーなんですけども...
僕は！！
僕はこの伸びるキーホルダーに
無限の可能性を、感じています。
このキーホルダー僕、無限の可能性があるんじゃないかなと思いまして
今回もう１００円ショップに売ってるの
全部買いまくってきました！
僕の街にある１００円ショップの
あのこの伸びるの全部買ってきました
約３０本！
３０本のこの伸びるキーホルダーを準備しました！
えげつねぇなぁ...
えげつねぇ量だ
うわ！こ、や...うわっ！
もう、ヤバいｗ
この、伸縮性のある
結局千切れないから商品化されてる訳でありまして...
伸ばしても千切れないんで沢山あったら
これをこうなんか
上手い具合になんかベッドっていうか
こうなんか板みたいにすれば
ハンモック作れるんじゃねぇかっと思いまして
そしたらもう伸縮性の
ふわっふわのハンモックが出来るわけですよ
というわけでこの伸びるキーホルダーだけで今日は
ハンモックを作ってみようと思います
では行こう！！！！
まず多分これ、一纏まりにしないといけないんで
とりあえずはもうこれが必須です
ハンガーにこうやって...
無理だ
これぐらいのサイズ感なら多分ちょうどいいはず
とりあえず全部一纏りにしないとは…あ〜待って
一纏りにできない
待って、見えた、見えた見えたこれ使います
ハンガーが太すぎてもうこれが通んないんで
それだったら通るような紐を使えばいいだけの話
この隙間にこうやって入れて
この手の紐は人の体重っていうか重いものには耐えれるんで
できましたこれだけ巻けば多分よっぽどのことないと千切れないんで
あーOK OKこの紐にこういう感じでとりあえず全部つけていきます
やばいなー俺その場のねぇ発想力は次元違い
はいこんな感じでございます
完璧
これをもうなんか適当なこういうとこにかけて
ここ繋げてこうするだけで多分もう
ああぁ！！あっ！
これ自体はもう完璧です
ここでよくね？
はいはいはい、きたきたきた
もう完全にもう勝利の方程式が見え始めております
んで後もう片方にもハンガーで同じような作りを作ります
はいっ！！！というわけで完成しました
両サイドハンガーで止めて何重にもしたビニール紐に
このキーホルダーのフックをかけて頑丈に固定いたしました
うぉまじで寝れそうじゃん
え？
キトゥー！
これ伸ばすとここでもう寝れるんじゃないかという僕の発想なんすよ
これ待ってどこまで伸ばせるんだろうそこが気になる
ちょっと伸ばしてみます
どこまで伸びるかをとりあえず知らなければ話にもなんないんで
いきます
あ待って助けてください　伸ばします
待って結構いけそうだなでも
や、まだいけるなぁ
えーこういうのがいっちゃん危ないって俺知ってんだよな
本当にやばい待ってください無理です無理です
待ってこれ動画の趣旨が変わって来る
あの僕あれがしたいんですよハンモックしたいだけ
これだとハンモック前に終わっちゃいそうな勢いですこれ多分
無理だよ待って違うんだよ
ハンモックしたいの違うのこれハンモックじゃなくなってる今待って…
待って
待って痛いの嫌だよ　待ってください
動画のタイトルとサムネももうハンモックできたみたいな感じになってるんで
ここで失敗すると動画のタイトルと違うことになってしまうんです
本当に待ってくださいまじでやばい
趣旨が変わってくる　待ってくださいもうちょっと
もうちょうっと頑張って欲しい
もうちょっと頑張ってお願い無理だよ無理だよこれ
(たなっち心の声：あ〜あまたやってるよこの人は)
はじめ：これ絶対飛んで来るもうだって
はじめ：いやこれハンモック
(たなっち：おれの予想だと)
はじめ：〜気がするんだけどな　どうですかね？
(たなっち：これははじめさんに飛んで来るね)
あ、いてぇーえ
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】
今回の失敗の原因はハンガーです
ハンガーが悪い
むしろこれからっすよって意気込んでたところで
ハンガーたちがちょっと耐えれなかったとこがありましたね
いや、非常に残念な結果になってしまいましたが
ハンモックは…
次回頑張ります
ありがとうございやした